لقد سمعنا الآن دعوات أخيرة لمزيد من
الدفاعات الجوية من الحلفاء الغربيين، ليس
فقط من زيلينسكي ولكن من
مسؤولين أوكرانيين آخرين بما في ذلك
وزير الدفاع الأوكراني أليكسي
ريزنيكوف الذي جلست معه في
نهاية هذا الأسبوع لإجراء مقابلة تلفزيونية حصرية،
كانت محادثة واسعة النطاق حيث كنا
بدأت بالحديث معه عن
قمة حلف شمال الأطلسي الأخيرة،
والإحباط الأوكراني بشأن عدم وجود
جدول زمني ملموس للانضمام إلى حلف شمال الأطلسي، وأخبرنا أن
لديه تاريخًا محددًا للغاية في ذهنه
عندما يمكن لأوكرانيا أن تصبح عضوًا في حلف شمال الأطلسي.
استمع،
إنه أمر مفهوم تمامًا أه  سيكون
قرارًا سياسيًا
بعد ذلك سننتصر في هذه الحرب
خلال هذه الحرب ليس لدينا
خيارات لإجراء تصويت بالإجماع لأن
المادة رقم خمسة وبعض الدول
ستكون مترددة
ولكن بعد النصر بعد ذلك
سننتصر في هذه الحرب سيكون ذلك في مصلحة
الناتو
لأننا أصبحنا الدرع الشرقي الحقيقي لحلف شمال
الأطلسي أو الدرع الشرقي لأوروبا،
أثبت الأوكرانيون أن لدينا
تجربة قتالية حقيقية في كيفية ردع الروس
لهزيمتهم وهزيمتهم والفوز
باستخدام
أسلحة الناتو القياسية، فكم
عدد الحجج التي يحتاجون إليها أكثر، لماذا تفعلون ذلك؟
أعتقد أن الولايات المتحدة لا
تقول إن اليوم التالي لهذه الحرب قد انتهى،
أوكرانيا ستكون عضوًا في حلف شمال الأطلسي (الناتو)، وأعتقد أن
ذلك ليس ضروريًا، لذلك سنواصل
تقديم إصلاحاتنا
خلال فترة الحرب هذه أيضًا ولكننا
سنواصل إصلاحاتنا،
وهذا يعني أنها
ستفعل ذلك.  سيكون بعد يوم واحد أو أسبوعين
ولكن تصوري أن
العام المقبل
سيكون قمة في واشنطن العاصمة، 75 عامًا من
تاريخ هؤلاء الحلفاء، من
يدري ربما سيكون
يومًا مهمًا للغاية بالنسبة لأوكرانيا، قد
تتوقع الانضمام إلى حلف شمال الأطلسي في غضون عام،
إنها مجرد توقعاتي
هل تعتقد أن العالم سينتصر بحلول
الصيف المقبل، نعم
وسننتصر في هذه الحرب،
إنها غضب شديد، إنها حزن، إنها دعوات
لمزيد من الدعم الدفاعي الجوي، تذكر أن هذه
هي الموجة الخامسة من الهجمات على أوديسا
في الأسبوع الماضي فقط بعد انسحاب روسيا  لقد
نجت أوديسا نسبيًا من إضرابات مثل
هذه خلال العام الماضي، ولكن بعد أن
لم تعد صفقة الحبوب سارية المفعول،
لم يعد هذا هو الحال، وكان الضرر الأسوأ
اليوم في وسط المدينة التاريخي
وهو أحد التراث العالمي لليونسكو  موقع
كنيسة التجلي، وهي
كاتدرائية تعرضت لأضرار جسيمة كانت
من بين 25 معلمًا معماريًا مختلفًا،
يقول مسؤول عسكري محلي
إن أضرارًا جسيمة لحقت بشخص واحد على الأقل
قتل حارس أمن،
ويقول الرئيس زيلينسكي يوم الأحد إن
أوكرانيا بحاجة إلى ما أسماه
درع السماء الكامل يقول أن هذه
هي الطريقة الوحيدة لهزيمة الإرهاب الروسي